it's great to welcome to the program
today Oliver thorn who's a professional
actor and also the creator of philosophy
tube a YouTube channel with about half a
million subscribers teaching philosophy
in fun interesting and I would say
well-produced ways is that is that fair
to say oh thank you that's very kind of
you it's a pleasure to be here so I mean
let for people not familiar with you to
talk a little bit about the the
philosophy piece of it I mean how long
have you been studying philosophy and
sort of like what's your relationship
generally to philosophy it was my first
degree and I started the show in my
second year of university I just wanted
to give away my degree for free online
that was six years ago and since then
it's become a phenomenon I guess one of
the things I like about what you do is
that there's a movement at least in the
United States where the right will often
successfully convert people to their
side by talking exclusively about
principles and I've long said that it's
great to understand what our principles
are and to be introspective and so on
and so forth but that a lot of the dirty
work or the work happens in actually
figuring out how to apply those
principles to real world problems and
very quickly realizing that oftentimes
those principles conflict one thing I
think you do well and I'm curious to
hear whether this is deliberate or one
of the primary things you're trying to
do is integrate the discussions of
principles from the get-go into how they
relate to real world problems and not
have this separation of all that matters
is the principles which which sometimes
happens with philosophical discussions
yeah definitely I always try to make the
philosophy relevant to everyday life I
mean that's that's half the fun and
that's half of what I try and do is say
no this isn't just some sort of ivory
tower academic like a PhD thing like
philosophy isn't relevant to people's
lives I think if that's the way you're
doing philosophy then I think I'll get
you're doing it wrong the whole point is
that it's it's sometimes life and death
and it's vitally interesting and and is
so interesting and important if you give
it a chance so yes I absolutely try to
do that deliberately are you trying to
reorient people
values or perspectives is that or how
would you how would you describe like
the goals of what you are doing is it
education does do you consider that it
goes beyond that into advocacy I think
it's definitely educational I also try
and take a bit of a new approach to
education
I find that certainly they're not
exclusively on the right often when
people talk about philosophy and
principles and education it's very
competitive it's like you need this so
you can win or you need this to be like
aggressive the analogy that I use is
like imagine if people only went to the
gym because they were training to be
street fighters it's like this is kind
of weird way of doing it where's what I
try and do is create an environment
where it's not competitive it's not
about like owning the lives or like
winning the debate
it's about curiosity not ambition is the
mantra that I that I try and use so yes
it's educational but also I've got a
kind of meta educational attitude
towards it which I try and bring across
in my work as well
have you heard anecdotally about people
whose worldview or at least their views
on particular issues have been
drastically altered by consuming your
content yeah big time I get emails
almost every day from people who say
that which is amazing and what's the
gist of it in the sense of I mean I
guess I have I have many questions about
this feel free to pick any of these that
you want to address first I mean are you
seeing what is the ideological change
that seems to most commonly be taking
place what is it specifically that
people say it was that changed their
minds I get a lot of emails from people
who say that they used to be all right
and then I found my work and they move
across I get a lot of emails from people
saying and that they they are still like
don't quite agree with everything I say
but they're starting to move across
after my video on abortion actually I
got a lot of people who who are pro-life
who said that I changed their mind which
was interesting and I might actually get
a lot of emails in particular from men
who are looking for a new way of being
masculine or approach to being
intellectual that isn't necessarily
competitive who say that they really
value that kind of environment that I
create so it's quite diverse
yeah yeah yeah but it's quite diverse
but I do get a lot of them yeah I took
get a lot of people writing to me saying
that I've sort of changed their outlook
on things and sometimes in subtle ways
and sometimes very drastic ways which is
it's always lovely can you talk a little
bit about that what you hear from men so
do you I think you said that was
interesting that people get from
you they get a different way of being
was it a different way of being
masculine and and it can just remind me
again how you said that that was
interesting yeah I do get a lot of
emails from from guys and people of all
genders but especially guys who say that
they're kind of looking for a way to be
masculine that isn't necessarily
competitive or aggressive and that they
find that the environment I create so
helps them do that a way to be
intellectual again that isn't about like
winning the debate while like training
for the fight but it's just about sort
of exploring it for their own sake and
having a curious attitude one of the
things I've expressed kind of concern
about is okay so at the 30,000 foot
level we or 10,000 meter level for lack
of a better term we have talked about
these algorithms that will often create
self-perpetuating feedback loops where
people are sort of pushed further and
further into more and more extreme
content I I believe it happens more on
the right but it could conceivably
happen on both sides of the political
spectrum and we could kind of have that
conversation and then I will also hear
from people much like you who say that
my content was at some point in their
deep programming phase something that
the algorithm suggested and got them out
of whatever ideology they had initially
been pulled into and one of the things
I've said is on an objective level I
think that this is good in that I think
the alt-right is a bad set of ideas and
if someone gets pulled out of that and
they come over to my side that's good at
the same time I have the concern that
there is a level of malleability to
people's values and politics whereby by
clicking around on YouTube they can get
so pulled to one side and then by mere
chance
algorithmic chance they get dragged all
the way back to the other side even if I
agree with the outcome I'm still
concerned that there is that level of
malleability do you share that concern
and what what's your sort of thought
about that I die I see where you're
coming from I understand the worry and
especially that it seems to be governed
by kind of big technological unseen
forces like the algorithm but at the
same time I think that's wonderful
if people can burn and change their
minds and that people remain curious
and that all it takes is like a little
knock on a door you haven't realized was
there and you can open it oh my god I
was wrong the whole time that's one of
the feelings that I love is when you go
oh my gosh I was completely wrong about
this and now I have an opportunity to
learn something wonderful than you and
something I'd never considered about
females I love the most I get in people
when people say I never thought about it
that way or I never thought about it at
all and that's that's wonderful because
then a whole whole new wing opens up in
your mind and so yeah I understand that
beautiful I'm that that is a certainly a
very charitable way to describe it and I
think in a lot of cases that that it
does apply and it simply is that way and
there isn't more to it I guess what I'm
thinking of is if I think of myself now
and 10 years ago and when I was in high
school or whatever I want to believe
that I was never in a place where by
clicking around on YouTube if I had seen
ben shapiro
and then stefan molyneux and then
whatever that i would have said oh you
know what I never thought about this
this way I'm now an extreme alt-right
nationalist whatever right like if that
had been possible I think it would have
said something not particularly positive
about me that I was so ungrounded in my
beliefs that they could have so
drastically been changed I guess that's
my concern well I mean how I almost went
down that path myself years ago I went
through a phase of him I went like a
Hitchens Dawkins atheist phase that was
gradually getting more and more
radically right-wing yeah but also I
mean 10 years ago I was I was what 16 so
I mean who really is that firmly
grounded in their beliefs at 16 or
indeed at any age that they can't be
persuaded I mean I understand the desire
to think oh god you know well I'm not I
don't like the idea that I could have
gone down that road but at the same time
there's something quite I think maybe
that speaks to that competitive mindset
there actually that's you know I don't
want to think of myself that I could
ever be persuaded by that but I mean it
could happen to all of us like yeah no I
mean I guess it's a matter of degree
right there's no questing that we should
all be completely insulated from the
idea of re-examining our beliefs our
considering some of our conclusions may
have been off but you know I guess I'm
reminded of there's this cultural critic
and arbiter of ideas named Dave Rubin
who you may be familiar with who nearly
at nearly 40 years old had almost a
hundred and eighty degree sort of
political realignment or awakening and
while he insists a lot of his positions
haven't changed like for example he's
for gay marriage it there's something
about that that if we believe it to be
genuine and not everybody does at that
age to exist in a way that you could so
radically be quote awakened something
about it I find concerning even without
disagreeing with you that being open to
new ideas and re-examining beliefs is of
course something we should we should
encourage I mean I I agree and I also I
see where you come from and saying that
it's concerning I think it's both
concerning on and kind of beautiful at
the same time can you talk a little bit
not to go completely often in that
rabbit hole can you talk a little bit
about is there a political philosophy
that is implicit in most of the sort of
status quo political conversations that
are happening today about neoliberalism
and social democracy or you know if we
look at like the most prevalent
political debates today is there a
philosophical underpinning that you
believe exists there but which most
people have not actually studied in
detail which would be particularly
useful to understand the political
debates that we're having I think
certainly a lot of the discussions I
have with people that revolve around
political philosophy people tend to come
at it from a liberal capital L liberal
point of view and I understand that in
the US people sometimes use the word
liberal differently so in the UK we I
would say that both the major political
parties in your country are capital L
liberals even though one of them is is
more conservative so I think often
people come at it from that from that
perspective
and it's sometimes you know I was raised
raised with that perspective so it's
kind of sometimes difficult to get out
from under it and I find it very
interesting and very rewarding and kind
of fun to make people aware of that
perspective and I did a series a while
ago it was quite a few years ago now
called what was liberalism which which
if a lot of people have written to me
saying hi you know I never thought about
it like that
which is quite interesting almost like
trying to step outside of it and look in
so I guess people learning a little bit
like what liberalism is and where it
comes from and how it's not sort of
built into the fabric of the universe
but in fact you can get curious about it
and change if you want to and I find
that to be a particularly rewarding
aspect of what I do what do you think is
a is a a specific alternative to that
type of status quo liberalism using you
know the word in the sense that you're
talking about that is most interesting
to point people to if they're looking to
explore alternatives I try not to point
people towards a specific tendency or
anything and but like one alternative to
liberalism would be fascism and another
would would I guess be left ISM so I I
would say that I'm a leftist and I
deliberately in public don't get any
more specific than that and but
certainly I find that a lot of people a
lot of people reflexively defend
capitalism without really having
necessarily thought about it or
everything that comes along with it and
sometimes it's it's fun to kind of pull
on that thread and think okay where did
you get this idea from and and I
describe it as like dislodging an idea
inside your head and saying where did I
get this and how does it work and do I
want to keep it or not and sometimes
people go yes actually I do know that I
understand that I do when I hang on to
this and that's fine and sometimes
people go actually you know what this is
kind of weird and what else have you got
there's a couple things that you do that
I'm curious about whether you do them
for a particular strategic reason or
they are merely the way you like to do
things or whatever the case may be one
is that your videos are produced in a
way that includes I'm I'm thinking that
they include scripts and sort of some
pretty specific thought as to what is
said and when sometimes costumes and
imagery and and things that sort of go
around the edges of the ideas is that
something you do merely because you
enjoy it is there some strategy behind
it I mean speculating the idea that
maybe helps appeal to people that might
be I don't know center-right gamers that
might get pulled in by the algorithm or
whatever the case may be I mean how much
of that is merely what you like to do
versus a strategic decision I mean it's
both so but perhaps for your viewers who
haven't seen any of my videos I should
say I will sometimes include I use a lot
of visual metaphor these a lot of
costumes and characters and narrative
devices in my video about abortion which
we mentioned earlier it was spliced in
with a short film that I made and and I
do all of that again both I partly
because I love it because as in my other
life I am a professional actor and Idol
I love theater and film and the use of
visual metaphor and telling a story that
way and but it also does help it does
help draw people and people get excited
about it people like it it's very
different it's something that not a lot
of people can do you know when I started
out on YouTube
nobody was summarizing Plato but now you
throw a stone in the woods and that
you'll hit 50 youtubers summarizing
Plato right so incorporating all that
stuff is kind of like something that
only that only I can do and and so it
brings my unique creative twist to it
which I love and and it does it does
help people learn in different ways
because there's more than one way of
skinning the cat you know sometimes
people will say I don't really get what
you mean by and by Timothy Morton's
concept of the hyper object of climate
change and I said well it's in front of
you because that's the costume I'm
wearing is like a visual representation
of his whole book on this philosophy so
maybe if people find it hard to engage
one way the quote theatrical stuff can
help do it the other way like I did a
video a while ago honor the philosophy
of mind and trauma and it's all one
uncut half-hour monologue there's no
cuts to it and that's not an accident
that's not just I'm rambling it's very
tightly scripted it's because that is
actually designed to tell you something
about what it's like to learn about
trauma and to learn about these ideas so
I do it because I love it and because it
works and because it's just yeah it's so
much fun if it helps people learn is
there a particular philosophical thought
line that you think is most acutely
missing from the sort of brains of
people that are discussing politics and
culture and the way that society should
be organized where if it was more known
to people we would all be far better off
so like I often talk about how there's
such a lack of critical thinking and
sort of learning how to learn and
understanding how propaganda works and
that that's like a set of knowledge that
would be very useful in general for a
lot of the conversations we're trying to
have when it comes to philosophy is
there something in particular that you
believe if more people studied and were
acquainted with we would be much better
position to figure out many of the
problems that modern societies deal with
I definitely agree with you about
propaganda and then it's it's it's
useful to learn how that works I guess
something that I then I have struggled
to find a way to teach um is not even an
idea or a set of ideas but more like a
set of skills that studying philosophy
formerly brought me which is like how to
read and break down an argument so
sometimes I will get comments under my
videos where people say well what about
this thing this one tiny thing that you
said invalidates everything else and I
go well no because that's actually not
really relevant that was a side comment
or that was an aside or that's not
actually if you take that out the rest
of it still works so there's something
about argumentative structure and like
logical structure that I have I think
picked up it's it's not not even a
language like almost a grammar of
philosophical arguments which I have
struggled to find a way to teach on its
own and then I'm always kind of thinking
about which which I think may be maybe
useful and it's it's not even like
reading comprehension it's something
even more basic now logical
comprehension and like something being
entailed by something else and like how
arguments fit together
I think would be really I I would find
it very useful but then perhaps that's
just me not knowing how to effectively
communicate with people who haven't had
that that study yeah I mean it is it is
a skill in and of itself how to teach
people how to teach themselves so to
speak or to teach people how to learn
and I 100% agree I mean both in my
academic experience and my media
experience it just seems acutely missing
from a lot of the conversations that
that were having about so many of the
most important issues of the day we've
been speaking with Oliver thorn who is
not only a professional actor but also
the creator of philosophy tube on
YouTube Oliver so great to speak to you
I really appreciate your time my
pleasure thank you so much for having me
this is so much fun